turning to europe now catastrophic
floods have killed more than 100 people
there
in germany and belgium those are the
hardest hit countries emergency crews
are desperately searching for hundreds
of people who are still unaccounted for
record amounts of rain look at this just
swept across the region destroying the
homes
and submerging the communities mts
tayyip has the latest on this story
the scale of the disaster is unlike
anything seen here
in living memory entire neighborhoods
now in ruins
after days of heavy rains triggered
flash flooding across large parts of
northern germany
torrents of water so powerful it crushed
much of what stood in its way
ensured a once quiet and picturesque
village
residents survey what's left
with this man saying it's unreal i can't
believe what i'm seeing here
dozens of people are dead tens of
thousands of homes are damaged
and power remains offline all after the
amount of rain that fell over a 48-hour
period
was double that of what normally would
have fallen for the entire month of july
german chancellor angela merkel who's in
washington for meetings with president
biden said
i grieve for those who have lost their
lives in this disaster
a nation bracing itself for the worst
after a disaster that shocked even
climate scientists
including ralph toomey from the imperial
college of london
we have manifestly one of the richest
countries in the world
being caught out which is quite
disturbing in the sense that suggests
that
no one is really safe neighboring
countries like belgium and the
netherlands have also been badly
affected
with several villages still cut off by
flood waters
and landslides now here's the thing
we know that climate scientists have
long been warning that global warming
would lead to this kind of extreme
weather but when we really think about
what's happening
in central europe and beyond well that's
really just
exceeded their expectations and the real
fear now
is that the worst is yet to come adriana
say it ain't so mts thank you so much
mts in london